[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the popular host
tuesday nba on tnt host the lefko show
on bleacher report adam lefkow joining
us on the program lefko good to have you
on
dan good to be here just want to say i
woke up today and you know sometimes
when the voice just feels crispy when
you wake up and you can't explain it
yeah
it's happening and i feel great oh that
oh that's a good sounding voice is what
you're saying
i mean i was getting ready to say that
you had a top five voice of all time and
i was hoping to one day stand in the
shadow of that voice but
seeing as how you're attacking today yes
yeah thanks dan good to see you as well
is that a cranberry velour shirt
is that velvet uh cranberry is an
interesting use of the word maroon
uh it is it's very soft i wanted you to
think that i had either expensive
pajamas uh or i just like have a strong
sweater game
it's kind of a merlot you're wearing
like a
what you're walking merlot yeah you know
i
for me it's more of a uh a pinot noir
okay
or uh yeah but merlot is nice and i like
by the way that traeger read earlier
thank you i almost bought a traeger
grill
i did was it that good i mean convincing
you could make cocktails on it yeah
i was like this is incredible we've made
cocktails we've made
uh pies on there and then you can make
anything you want really
wow incredible but you're a big time i
mean
you should be able to afford a traeger
grill i don't i have never lived in a
place in which a grill
could exist have you either been in new
york for eight years i'm currently in an
airbnb in atlanta i don't know what it's
like to have a yard dan
i'm not an adult yet it's an issue and
you went with the turtleneck you're
rocking the turtleneck
is that it i like it i'm just worried
about turtleneck
late march early april in atlanta
uh i kind of came into it and i said
ernie in that chair has taken
bow ties and made it iconic and the last
thing i wanted to do was to be another
suit and tie okay
you know that that's over and i i kind
of looked around and i said
when i think back to my college
experience who is the creepiest person
oh the old guy that comes back in a
turtleneck and i tried to channel that
uh i'm just having fun and the greatest
thing with mba on tnt
is that people feel comfortable
insulting you
and then i get the opportunity to clap
back at them which has been
very enjoyable all right uh did anything
change yesterday in the nba
as far as seismic shift the uh
the power rankings there for me
the team that caught my attention the
most maybe surprisingly was the denver
nuggets
uh i i really thought the denver nuggets
were going to have a big second half
mainly because they had so much depth
that was hurt in the first half
and when i looked at them i was like
nicole yolk has just been
carrying this team by himself 12 13
triple doubles
but now he has athleticism and size
around him aaron gordon javale mcgee
won jokic's ability to pass that two-man
game now with aaron gordon
i don't need you to dribble go run at
the hoop jokic is going to hit you
but when they lost jeremy grant when
they lost plumley last year
that along with jamal mary and jokic
gave a lot of depth and
it really seems like the nba went
anthony davis is a ways away according
to frank vogel
and lebron james we don't see him get
hurt that often
it was as if everybody woke up denver
caught my attention because now i think
they have the athletic
bigs and when i look at the clippers
they don't have the bigs when i look at
the lakers
gasol's still trying to work on his
conditioning they don't really have the
bigs right now so denver really caught
my attention
and i always wondered that though adam
if somebody was going to be
like counterintuitive of hey we can't
match you with
this so we need you to try to match what
we do
now you deal with us as opposed to us
trying to be
like everybody else in the nba is that
what denver's doing
sure does seem like it i i like the fact
that there was a number of teams that
maximized the short window of their
stars and were honest about it
don't wait for gary trent jr to become
norman powell
get norman powell don't wait for zach
levine to maybe get to free agency and
go i wonder what it would be like to be
with an athletic big
get vuchevich put him out there and so
for denver
uh they're like i we don't think last
year was a fluke
we don't think that the jamal murray
that we saw in the bubble
all of a sudden went away it's funny the
bubble guys are starting to come back
jamal murray is starting to come back
tyler heroes starting to come back
we forget that they had like three weeks
between the end of the bubble and the
regular season we're like why isn't this
continuing so
uh i i don't think denver was a flash in
the pan and i think they were
let's get some athletes around yokic and
make it easier for them i
mentioned this about 30 minutes ago can
you remember a player who
averages four points a game and gets as
much attention as rajon rondo does
um i thought you're going to talk about
kelly olynyk i think you're going to say
you ever see someone get four points a
game they get traded for like a
former all-star uh rondo has
so much respect from every nba player
when that trade you know because let's
be honest chat gets out there i need
i need a list of the truths so he can
look at them you know and he goes oh
rondo
it's his iq we've read the stories
before about how nobody
learns the pocket of a shooter of his
team
better than rondo and puts those perfect
passes the leadership that's the reason
they brought him to atlanta
was to mentor trey and the whole
experience with the coach there didn't
work out
but it is interesting that when i was
looking at the crunch time numbers the
under five minutes for the clippers
how much everything fell apart and it
turned into iso ball where it was
paul george figure it out kawhi figure
it out and now that
rondo can be out there the other thing
that i love is
mantras harold goes from the clippers to
the lakers
and it felt like this backstabbing and
it's now like the clippers got their
former laker from last year
to come right so i i pray that
if the lakers do fall they fall to a
spot in like six or seven to where they
have to play the clippers in the first
round because that would be unbelievable
rondo a hall of famer
oh man i feel like a lot of people are
hall of famers
uh the pro basketball or the basketball
hall of fame is very loose
uh but he's got a number of titles i i
said he was but they're far more lenient
with the basketball hall of fame
i don't think he won anything at
kentucky in his what one year there
no i believe but billy gillespie yeah i
i feel
like rondo is a hall of fame going to
the hall of fame
i hear a lot of people just say hall of
famer you know so yeah i i would i mean
i'm hearing
kyle lowry's a hall of famer uh really
rudy gobert is a hall of famer these are
things i hear people say all the time
because you look and you're like oh rudy
gobert's a two-time defensive player of
the year oh yeah yeah
and it's we we look at the it's tough
because it's we look at them in a vacuum
but it nba's lose i just know that
whenever the hall of fame comes up
shaq is like i wish it was tighter it's
the hall of very good
like he he only wants like him kareem
will like that's all he wants in there
yeah we are a lot more lenient when it
comes to
basketball uh because you have to we
know nothing of the process dan
it's not like the nfl where we know
there's this conference room and there's
writers and we know
who's pitching you and what was the
argument against you and we know the
votings the nba it's like hunger games
and they're like and these are the six
names and we're like wait how did you
how did you get there like how did that
happen nobody is allowed to know
yeah uh i saw the the latest odds after
the trade deadline it's the nets the
lakers and then the clippers
i like what have the clippers done
that would make you think they're the
third best team to win a championship
here
maybe i'm biased but i thought the
sixers would be ahead of the clippers
i mean embiid's out and they've won
eight of eight and one
in their last night i got the bucks and
the jazz and then the sixers
with these odds i mean tobias harris is
only up to season average by
five to like 25 points per game simmons
is like a walking triple double
and he sometimes doesn't even need
points to even come near it
uh they now add george hill that that's
interesting
the bucks are slept on and i'm a part of
the problem
because i am one of those media members
that has suffered bucks fatigue and
budenholzer fatigue
and i'm sitting there going you haven't
adapted in the playoffs the last three
years
and i'm self-consciously worrying that
they're going to pull a raptors
where that when they won everybody was
like yeah well prove it to me in the
playoffs and we just write them off all
season long
um i i love the pj tucker edition and i
think
we've forgotten that drew holiday is
there and he missed a large chunk of
time with kovid
and then the nets though to me are the
most fun watch in the nba
and at the end of the day we can look at
odds but i think they're the best team
in the nba
because you have hardened kyrie and
durant and when those guys are clicking
i don't know who's stopping them because
playoff basketball is half court
basketball and it's a one-on-one game
and all three of those guys are a
walking bucket
but the lakers i have a real concern
with if if
anthony davis has a calf strain which is
the same injury that kevin durant had
before he popped his achilles we cannot
take it lightly
because it's also a mental thing for
lebron
he has played 93 percent of the games
that his teams have had he has missed i
think in his career
104 games he has played almost
50 000 minutes and missed 104 games and
not all those were injuries
a lot of those were just let's get some
rest on the second half of a back to
back
and so when he went down writhing in
pain
it is open but yeah i'm i'm with you
with the clippers where i go
okay where's the big guy that's going to
defend embiid if he's there or
or defend if the nets end up pulling
anybody else or anthony davis is
if he's healthy and and look i love paul
george he's having a career
true shooting season but we we've seen
this story before and it's not one that
i enjoy reading
keep rocking the velour keep rocking the
turtleneck
but just keep on rocking in the free
world okay anna um
that was great by the way can i ask one
quick question before you kick me off
yes you can you told me to be
stockton yes um
man i want to be iverson and i just want
to know did you have any other
broadcasting
hosting advice or analysis of what i
need like what do i
really suck at dan um
but there's nothing wrong with starting
at stockton because your job is to
distribute
but when you want to call your own
number
then it'll stand out even more if you
call your number all the time
then i think you get in the way of the
people who they've done this before
but when you want to go and and you can
be magic johnson
against the sixers in the nba finals and
you know go for 42 points
but the other times your job is to set
those guys up you got to have at least
10 assists a night
hmm i like that you mentioned magic in
the finals
because he saved it for the stage yeah
okay yeah i mean that was correct pick
your spot
you didn't do it here but pick your spot
when you want to be really good okay
that burn brought to you by trigger
grills
not going to do it on our grills yeah do
it on the show look at that voice how
listen to that voice
not as good as this voice no not as good
as this voice yeah we know yeah
yeah keep your head up okay thanks pal
all right that's adam lefkow
tuesday nba on tnt host oh wait till
they give him like wednesday and
thursday
and friday